翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Masahide Naraoka
（英語でベイリーに指示）
みなさん こんにちは
森田優子です
こちらは ファシリティドッグのベイリーです
みなさん 子どもの頃
注射って怖くなかったですか？
学校での予防接種 —
先に終わった子に
「痛かった？痛かった？」って
聞いて回りませんでしたか？
子どもにとって 注射とか採血って
ものすごく怖いんですよね
入院中の子どもは
何度も何度も採血をします
骨髄穿刺といって
太い針をグリグリっと腰の骨に刺す
検査が必要な子もいます
ここにいるベイリーは —
そんな検査も
「ベイリーと一緒なら
あと100回やりたい」って
子どもに言わせる力を持っています
日本の医療は世界最高水準だと
言われています
でもそれは病気を治す
治療でのことです
がまんすることが美徳とされてきた日本は
入院生活の質を上げるための
サポートが乏しいと 言われています
私はかつて 東京のこども病院で
看護師をしていました
ある日 入院中の子どものお母さんに
「ここはまるで牢獄ですね」
と言われたんです
自分では精一杯 子どもたちのことを思って
仕事をしていたつもりだったので
そんなことを言われて
すごくショックでした
でも 事実 入院中の子どもは
自由に散歩にも行けない —
好きな食べ物を持ってきてはいけない —
楽しみが少ないんです
笑わなくなってしまう子もいます
今思えば それは 牢獄だと言われても
仕方がなかったかも知れません
そんな時 —
私がいま所属している
「シャイン・オン・キッズ」
というNPO法人から
ファシリティドッグの
ハンドラーとしての 誘いを受けました
日本の小児がん 難病の子どもたち
その家族を
心の面でサポートするための
NPO法人です
その時は 犬を
こども病院に連れて行って
医療スタッフの一員として
勤務する仕事らしい —
ファシリティドッグという犬は
欧米にはたくさんいるけれど
日本にはまだいないらしい —
その程度の知識しかありませんでした
でも この病棟に犬がいたら
牢獄と言われた 子どもたちの入院生活
どれだけ楽しくなるだろう？って
ワクワクしました
迷わず 「やります！」って
言いました
ファシリティドッグのトレーニングセンターは
日本にはありません
ベイリーも私も ハワイの
トレーニングセンターで訓練を受けました
ハワイの子ども病院で
先輩ファシティティドッグの
後をついて回る練習もしました
そのファシリティドッグは
重症の患者を集中治療する
ICU病棟にも入って行ったんです
そこには 髪の毛を半分そられ
頭に大きな傷のある
手術直後の子がいました
つらそうに顔をしかめていました
「こんな大変なときに行っていいの？」と
心配する私をよそに
そのファシリティドッグは
身体中に管のついた
その子のベッドに乗って
添い寝を始めたんです
すると その子の表情が
ふーっと ゆるみました
体を動かすのは つらいはずなのに
その犬に抱きついて
目をつぶったんです
本当に安心した表情になりました
それを見て
「すごーい！」って思いました
「私も病院中を笑顔にできるぞ」
と思って
ベイリーを連れて
日本に帰って来たのですが
それまで日本には
ファシリティドッグなんていません
欧米と日本では
犬に対する感覚が違うんですよね
欧米では 犬は家族の一員として
家の中で飼うのが当たり前の文化でした
でも日本は犬を
外で飼ってきた歴史があります
「犬を病院の中に入れるなんて」
というのが
日本の病院の感覚だったんです
それまで 日本にも 時々ボランティアで
病院にやってくる犬たちはいました
でも 犬を毎日病院の中に入れる —
犬を医療スタッフの一員として考える
という感覚がなかったんです
「ハワイでは こうだった」は
日本では全く通じません
私たちは ベイリーを受け入れてくれる病院を
必死で探しました
ようやく受け入れてくれたのが
静岡県立こども病院でした
でも実際に活動を始めてみると
「犬型ロボットじゃだめなの？」
「感染症が心配だから
この病棟は入らないで」
初めは 入れる病棟は
１つしかありませんでした
だから １日の仕事は数分で終わりです
出勤してきた１時間後には
もう退社です
「日本ではファシリティドッグは
受け入れられないのかな？」と
私の頭には不安しかありませんでした
でも 子どもたちは
ベイリーを求めていたんです
５年が経った今では
ほとんどの病棟に入れるようになっています
「ベイリーがいると 子どもたちと
家族に 良い変化があるんだ」と
医師や看護師が気付き始めていったんです
ある 目の見えない子は
採血の時にはいつも
パニックになって泣き叫んでいたのに
ベイリーが隣りにいて
頭を撫でながら採血したら
泣かずにできました
手術後 痛くて動こうとしなかった子が
ベイリーに会いたさに
ガバッと起き上がって
医師を驚かせました
突然 「あなたのお子さんはガンです」と
宣告されたご家族 —
家族は 子どもが不安になるので
子どもの前では気丈に振る舞います
でも ずっと自分の気持ちを抑え込んでいると
いつか限界がきます
泣くことも大事なんです
そこにいる相手が人間だと
「何か喋らなきゃ」って思います
でも ベイリーには
無理に喋る必要はありません
あるお母さんは 廊下で
ベイリーを抱きしめて思いっきり泣いて
すっきりした表情で
子どもの許に戻って行きました
ベイリーは 家族にも
大きな効果があったんです
私は ファシリティドッグにとって
大切な３つの絆があると気付きました
ベイリーと子どもたち
ベイリーとハンドラー
ベイリーと医療スタッフ
この３つの絆です
１つ目の絆は —
ベイリーは 毎日
同じ病院で仕事をしているので
何度も同じ子に会います
子どもたちにとって
ただ犬がいれば良いのではありません
毎日来てくれるベイリーだから良いんです
絆で結ばれているベイリーだから
「がんばろう」って思うんです
初めは犬嫌いだった子も
ほとんどの子はベイリーを好きになります
子どもたちにとって ベイリーは共に闘う
尻尾の生えた仲間なんです
ベイリーは子どもと一緒に
手術室まで行くこともできます
大人でも 手術を受けるのって
怖いですよね
「痛いのかな？怖いな」って
病棟から手術室まで
子どもにとっては恐怖の時間です
でも ベイリーのリードを持って
一緒に歩くと
「こっちだよ」ってベイリーを
誘導しながら 笑顔で歩いて行きます
手術室までのお散歩は
みんなのベイリーを独り占めできる時間です
ベイリーのフサフサとした尻尾に
猫のようにじゃれつきながら歩く子もいれば
「尻尾でがんばれって言ってるね」って
嬉しそうに笑う子もいます
こうして 怖い気持ちが
楽しい気持ちに変わって
手術室まで向かって行きます
２つめの絆
ファシリティドッグとハンドラーは
24時間 生活を共にしています
お休みの日もいつも一緒です
これが大切で 仕事の時だけ一緒にいて
仕事が終わったら 「じゃあ バイバイ」
ではダメなんです
私とベイリーは 夜は腕枕して
一緒に寝てるんですよ
ファシリティドッグとハンドラーとの絆 —
これがファシリティドッグが
仕事をする上での基盤になります
私との絆があるから
ベイリーは 私を信頼して
仕事をしてくれるんです
でも 実は
トレーニングを受けた犬というと
何でも言うことを聞く犬と思われがちですが
ベイリーは困ってしまうほどの頑固坊主です
行きたい方向にしか進みません
行きたくない方向にはこうです
すっごい 踏ん張っているの
分かりますか？
ガッと脚を広げて 爪を立てて
行きたくない方向には絶対に進みません
散歩中も道で座り込んで
私がベイリーと
こう 格闘していると
「大変ね」って
道行く人に笑われています
でも 病院に行くのを
「嫌」って言ったことは一度もありません
逆に帰るときには「まだ帰らない」—
座り込んで
また病院の中に戻って行ってしまいます
犬は相手が自分のことを
どう思っているのかすぐに感じ取ります
自分のことを愛してくれる人が
たくさんいる場所
だから ベイリーも 病院が大好きなんです
人と犬と相思相愛 —
これがファシリティドッグの
真髄だと思います
愛情のやりとりのない
犬のぬいぐるみではダメなんです
ロボットではダメなんです
ベイリーと医療スタッフ —
これが３つ目の絆です
ファシリティドッグのハンドラーは
医療従事者です
なぜ 医療従事者が
ハンドラーになるのでしょうか？
それはファシリティドッグは
癒しだけではなく
治療にも関わっていくからです
私とベイリーは
患者さんの治療方針を決める
話し合いの場に参加することもあります
その場で 私も患者さんの状態を把握して
その子に合わせた関わり方を
考えていきます
カルテへの記載もします
この 目的を持って関わっていくということが
ファシリティドッグにしか
できないことであり
ハンドラーが
医療従事者である理由でもあります
私とベイリーが日本で仕事を始めて
５年が経ちました
これまで何千人もの
子どもたちとの出会いがありました
病状が悪化していき ごはんが
食べられなくなってしまった
終末期の子がいました
食べたいけれど 食べられない
そんな状態でした
残された時間が少ない中で
家族も 看護師さんも
なんとか少しでも
食べさせてあげたかったんです
そんな時 「ベイリーと一緒に
ごはんを食べたらどうか」と提案がありました
ベイリーと一緒だと
笑顔で一緒に座りました
そして 「ベイリー 見ててね」と言って
ほんの数口ではありましたが
自分でスパゲッティをつかんで
口に入れたんです
アイスクリームをパクパク食べました
いやいやではなく 楽しそうに
その場にベイリーがいるだけで
これだけ変わるんです
「ベイリーに会いたいから 入院したい」
と子どもに言わせるほど
病院のイメージが変わるんです
ベイリーと一緒だと
楽しい気持ちは倍増
悲しい気持ち 怖い気持ちは
半分こできるんです
ほとんどの子は元気に退院していきます
でも 残念ながら お星様になって
旅立って行く子もいます
お空に旅立つ直前まで
ベッドで添い寝することもあります
「ベイリーが隣りにいるの
分かるでしょう？」
「暖かいね」って
悲しいけれど 暖かい
そんな時間が流れています
お子さんのご葬儀に
参列させていただくこともあります
火葬場で最後に
棺のふたを閉めるときの
ご両親の気持ち
想像してみてください
でも ご家族はいつも
「ベイリーがいてくれて
本当に良かった」って
言ってくれます
「ベイリーがいなかったら
つらいだけの入院生活だった」
「ベイリーが来て がらっと変わった」って
言ってくれます
子どもを亡くしたご家族は
その後の長い人生の中
毎日 その子のことを思い返します
「何度も手術して痛い思いして
可哀想だった」って思い返すのと
「亡くなる前にもベイリーと添い寝して
くっついて笑ってたっけな」って
思い返すのとでは
気持ちが全然違いますよね
ほんの少しでも つらい思い出の中に
楽しい思い出も作れたら良いと思います
１つでも多く その子の笑顔を
思い返して欲しいです
ファシリティドッグは
「いたら良いな」の存在ではなく
必要な存在なんだと
強く感じています
世界最高水準だと言われている
日本の医療 —
ただ病気を治すだけではなく
もっと前向きに 病気を治せる
環境が必要だと思います
患者さんにとって
楽しいこと 嬉しいことは
いくら多くてもいいんです
欧米にはたくさんいるファシリティドッグ
日本にはまだ２頭です
ファシリティドッグがいて当たり前の日本 —
入院しても 楽しいことがある
日本の病院にしていきたいです
本当にたくさんの可愛い子どもたちが
お星様になって
私たちを見守ってくれています
あの子たちに 自信を持って
「良い病院になったでしょう？」と言える
日本の医療現場に
していきたいと思っています
（拍手）